[Musique]
la propagation du coronavirus force
maintenant la mise en quarantaine de
billets de banque
salle monnet le collier influenza est
maintenant coronavirus les études ont
démontré que les billets de banque en
papier peuvent héberger jusqu'à 3000
virus et bactéries qui peuvent survivre
pendant deux semaines et que 94 % des
billets en circulation dans le monde
sont contaminés pour freiner la
propagation du coronavirus la chaîne a
passé des millions de yuans aux rayons
ultraviolets pour les désinfecter en
corée du sud on va chauffer les billets
à 150 degrés celsius pendant trois
secondes pour tuer les virus même les
états unis vont mettre en quarantaine
les billets américains que des touristes
prat même de l'étranger
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
priorise donc les paiements sans contact
mais attention votre téléphone aussi
héberge des milliers d re ces bactéries
[Musique]